violence in our valley schools one
teacher tells us she was recently
attacked by a student madison kimbrough
spoke with her today and joins us with
her story
this is the first time we're hearing
directly from a ccsd teacher about being
assaulted this happening the same day as
the school board meeting that was on
school violence while she didn't want to
give her name or the middle school she
works at she says she is now
contemplating whether teaching is
something she wants to continue as she
is a first year teacher this incident
happened during first period on friday
when an apparent fight broke out between
two girls when the teacher tried to stop
it she then ended up getting attacked in
the process stating that she was punched
several times with her hair pulled and
also tackled now she's left wondering
what her next move will be as she's
never experienced anything like this
before it makes me question like
is this what i work so hard to get into
i mean i woke up the next today and i'm
sore and my head hurts and i'm kind of
still wrapping my head around what
happened as for the students involved
both were suspended she says faculty had
her fill out a report but then she ended
up working the rest of the day when she
came to it was her other student
surrounding her asking if she was ok and
in the numbers we obtained from ccsd it
shows that there are over 5 300 cases of
school violence this school year alone
reporting near wrestle and highway 95
madison kimbrough live local now